pitching a path to power a general
election some time off but the campaign
now very much on I didn't realize we're
gonna have all the people up on the
other floors this a leader on the up
imposed now laying down his plans for
office Mission driven government an
answer to the widespread call to fix the
fundamentals a long-term plan to unlock
our pride and our purpose a profound
statement of intent
five missions to grow the economy and
improve opportunities become a clean
energy Powerhouse improve the NHS and
make our streets safe but will it cut
through people want their country to
work but can you honestly say that your
Blue Sky Thinking rather than clear
specific policies such as cutting work
in people's taxes or ensuring that
they'll get a Hospital appointment is in
any way relatable you're quite right to
say look what's what are you gonna do
about the NHS this winter what are you
going to do about energy bills this
spring but the problem if we stop there
with that sort of retail offer for the
here and now is that we'll never fix the
fundamentals we've had 13 years of
sticking plaster politics we've had 13
years of going round around in circles
people here have an appetite for change
but they're not yet sure what that looks
like
is keeping everything vague enough that
it you know ticks all the boxes without
actually
cementing a position do you sort of feel
you know what he stands for
uh not particularly you think storm is
better for the labor party there's more
chance of getting elected it doesn't
matter what you do then or who you vote
for like nothing will change yeah 100 so
you don't trust any politicians
and that lack of trust is hurting the
conservatives labor and now 25 plus
points ahead in the polls not
necessarily because people like labor
but rather they seem to dislike this
conservative government and circular
starma is now trying to begin to seal
the deal with voters these five missions
will form the skeleton of the next Labor
Manifesto but what it all boils down to
is still so very vague there's still no
meat on the bones when it comes to
either policy or priorities
he can't quite believe his luck after
suffering the worst election defeat
since 1935 bringing labor back must have
felt like Mission Impossible but there's
still some way to go yet Beth Rigby Sky
News in Manchester